In this section of our course, we will go through a hands-on exercise where we will use the Mesh to MetaHuman workflow with the template, or also known as the conformed mesh option to create a metahuman identity.
We will primarily work in Unreal Engine, and as we work through this exercise, you will note that this is broken down into a step-by-step process that is found in your slide deck.
As we complete portions of the practical exercise, I will review the completed steps.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine and begin going through the steps of this workflow.
Inside of Unreal Engine, let's begin by going to our course folder named MEH21302.
In the assets folder in the folder named conformed mesh atomic savage, I have already gone through the steps of importing the fitted head mesh of the stylized character atomic savage.
I will double-click on this to open it.
If you wish to go through the steps of importing this yourself, you can find the original obj file in the source files folder of our course.
For this workflow, we will be using this head mesh.
You do not need to apply a material to this, as this will not be solved based on image.
I have gone ahead and applied a material that is using the metahuman identity texture to demonstrate that this has been fitted in a way that respects all of the important edges and loops.
I am going to close this and return to the main viewport.
Now let's navigate to our course topics folder.
In the folder named conformed mesh to metahuman, you will find a metahuman identity that has been solved with the template mesh option that you can inspect.
Now let's go to the conformed mesh to metahuman example folder.
Inside of here, I have created a blank metahuman identity asset and named it.
Let's double-click on this to open it.
As you can see, this is empty and we are going to populate it.
For the first step, instead of going to the create components dropdown over here in the toolbar, we will go up here to asset and select it.
Then all the way down here, we will select configure components from conformed.
We are going to search for the static mesh named atomic as conformed, which is right here and then select it.
Now that this head mesh is loaded, I am going to navigate to the front of it so that we can see it better.
The second step is to select the body component and right below select a body type.
In this case, I want to choose medium masculine overweight.
The third step is to go to the mesh to metahuman dropdown here and select auto rig metahuman identity, skeletal mesh and full metahuman.
You may be prompted to sign in with your Epic Games account.
Once you do, it will send this to the metahuman backend.
When this process completes, a notification will appear, letting us know that the skeletal mesh has been embedded with metahuman DNA
and that this is also available in the creator and bridge.
Since atomic savage is much larger than standard metahumans, this also informs us that the identity face scale is 1.329 times that of an average metahuman,
which may indicate an issue with the input data.
It recommends that the input mesh be less than 25% away from the scale of an average metahuman face.
This is fine for our specific character, so I'm going to click OK.
Now I will navigate to our main viewport and in the content browser, we will see the skeletal mesh that was generated.
I'm going to double click on this to open it and I will dock it up here.
Even though there is still more work to do, this workflow helps to get the geometry and joint positions closer to the target delta.
The atomic savage character is a good example for demonstrating the kinds of results you may get when using a stylized face whose facial features go beyond the golden triangle of the face.
The last step of this workflow is to go to the metahuman creator, inspect the results and make adjustments if needed before downloading the source assets.
Now let's do a quick review before we move on.
We have just gone through the steps of the mesh to metahuman workflow using the template mesh option.
The requirement for this workflow is that we use a mesh that has been fitted to metahuman topology.
To get started, import the head mesh, which in our case we use the atomic savage conformed OBJ file that has been fitted to a custom sculpt already.
With the head mesh imported, the first step is to create a metahuman identity asset and configure it.
Inside of the metahuman identity asset window, go to asset and select configure components from conformed and from there search for the head mesh and select it.
An error will appear if the mesh is not compatible with metahuman topology.
Next, select the body component and then select a body type.
The second step is to go to the mesh to metahuman drop down option and select auto rig metahuman identity, skeletal mesh and full metahuman, as we will want the source assets for the final fitting.
The metahuman identity will be solved using the input mesh we have assigned, which will result in the geometry and joint positions closer to our target delta and across all LODs.
When working with stylized characters such as this one, there will still be more work to do.
One of the things that can help to reduce the amount of work that is needed is to use the metahuman creator.
For stylized characters such as atomic savage, the region influence in the metahuman creator can help save considerable time, but at the expense of losing likeness.
The top two images show us what the tear duck region of the head mesh looks like with and without using the region influence.
The tear duck region of the head mesh as well as the majority of the additional assets such as the cartilage and the eye shell are fitted to the eye region.
And these may also need to be manually adjusted if the region influence is not used to correct issues.
The mouth region, particularly the lip contact, is another area that may need adjusting.
Again, the region influence will save considerable time, but as demonstrated in the animated gift below, at the expense of losing likeness.
Once you are finished making adjustments in the creator, the last step is to download the source assets in order to complete the final fitting process.
Now, let's move on to the next section where we will go over best practices for finalizing the fitting process.